thank you
thank you very much for coming the
people who stick to the last talk
they're really here for the science
right so uh thank you for sticking
around
um this is the last talk I'm sure that's
your old Tire I'll try to keep it on the
light side yeah
simple theorems pictures and and such
like
poisoning okay
so uh so the talk is really about you
know adversaries versus machine learning
and you might have you know an awesome
uh uh model that you know can you know
in isolation without any
right interaction with the adversy it
can't answer you know very well right it
might say yeah you know um
is this topic really important and it
comes up it's you know very nice answer
about it seems to be uh pretty good
Workshop
your fire is ready yeah
and then and then the adversary comes
and tries to change this into something
that is a little bit different right
um and then the answer but just a little
bit changing the um
the sentence you're putting a knot in it
then suddenly it says well it maybe
you'll consider less important but some
people right
uh
and then it gives a huge list of why it
is considered less important okay
uh so and you choose not include that
yeah well it was just too long and then
maybe yeah
maybe maybe yeah I skip it for okay
uh so basically uh when the adversary
comes into the picture to our usually
grouped into two categories okay either
you know we have a training time attack
or the test time attack and I'm going to
briefly explain what they are and what
I'm going to talk about today
the test time attacks are you know very
popularized yeah we and we have seen a
lot of examples about them so a machine
learning pipeline is usually something
like this we have the data we fit it
into a learner
it gives us a model
we give
a test example you know this is a
workshop what is a workshop and it gives
the right answer it is you know very
nice equations Divergence entrepreneurs
it should be about information Theory
good sounds like right
okay
now
there is a
when you have an adversary
in the test time attack the adverse it
adds a little bit of noise
such that the answer changes okay so the
addressee has access to the test point
and then
it adds some sort of noise and then
suddenly it becomes another program
which is
an adversary approaches in machine
learning which is a completely different
program with a different Banner
all right from Simon's
so that is what the adversary wants to
do okay so that is a test time attack
and I'm not going to talk about it today
uh so the goal is to have low accuracy
what I'm going to talk about today is a
training time attack the goal is the
same the adversary wants to
confuse the model it wants to make sure
that you make a mistake by controlling
the model
but it doesn't have access to the model
so what does it do
it's going to
poison the training data it changes a
few points from the tiny data
then the learner is going to get that
poisonous data points
and the model is going to change a
little bit and the goal is that this
model and this data
is going to predict something that is
not correct
that's the goal of the training time
attack
and these attacks surprisingly
appear in large scale
and Industrial applications because if
you have a huge amount of data you can
never check whether you know how you
collect the decision amount of data you
cannot check individually whether
they're good or not
and some
malicious players can actually plant
very bad data so that you make a mistake
on a particular date
Okay so
uh
I hope that the distinction is clear
between uh test time attack and the
training time
I've been waiting for you to ask that
question making a pour over
that was a big driver
s
yeah
it's a poisonous company
um I'm afraid Okay so
this is like a presumption Because
unless you attack a certain number of
those samples
first if I was a very large data curator
like a power grid operator
maybe a new cut come in and do this
that's what then this weird setting I
could see this happen but
um
you have to
attack a certain number of times so
presumably you're going to tell us all
that stuff I'm hoping yes the the point
is exactly answering that question
um
so uh what we're going to talk about is
what is called the instance targeted
data point setting what does it mean I
have a given
give given an instance X Y so that's a
data point it can be like this
particular data point
the adversary makes changes to the data
set
so that the learner's output model gives
the wrong prediction so the label from
Green
flips to a red one okay
just just to plug in we have been doing
this work with irfa where they want to
know if you have a back door so imagine
you of the model in this is a sort of
not really poison data but you have
Trojan data so you have learned your
model on something that gives you
advantage there is also it is very well
it is also related to what is called the
vector attacks yes
what can happen in circuits and stuff
and if you have another Target
then the adverse is going to change
a different set of training data so that
the prediction is going to be different
um
so to be more precise what we have is a
set of classifiers it is called the
concept class or the hypothesis class it
can be the set of linear classifiers or
uh neural Nets over domain X these are
the data points
so we call every pair of data point
label
as an example
and we have a training set s of n many
examples
and another test example X Y that are
drawn from the same distribution unknown
distribution
an adversary may replace some of the
examples in s with our virtual examples
of each choice
and the goal of the learner is to design
a mapping
that Maps every set s to a classified
Edge
such that the probability of erase means
even when it is exposed to
malicious statements
poisonous right so that's a book
foreign
but a simple example let's consider the
set of classifiers over the surface
two-dimensional space the all linear
classifiers
and uh
so this is the training data sample from
a distribution
just by eyeballing I think you can say
where the classifier should be right
this is the classifier
that is realized it we are going to talk
most of the target is going to be about
the realizable setting meaning that
there is a classifier such that the
error is zero
okay
and then I'm going to
draw another data point x
from the same distribution if you look
at it I think you can guess what the
label should be right should be negative
let's assume that there is going to be
an adversary that can change at most
four database
all right
and what the adversar is going to do is
that
foreign
so it's going to change
those for the label of those four data
points and suddenly there's going to be
another hypothesis from the class
that is also realizable
but the prediction is going to be
different from the actual prediction
right
so the adversary is successful
you're doing that
good
okay so before talking about uh you know
what we have done let me actually say
what others did
so the problem you know one of the first
studies was done by steinhardt that you
know they look at data poisoning attacks
and try to understand you know when we
can have algorithms that certify
uh certifiably obtained an expected low
risk so certification in this context
means that even if I change a few data
points
you can certify when you predict that
the label is plus or minus you can
certify that the the label is not going
to change
even if
I change these many data points it
doesn't mean that the label is correct
the reason label is not going to change
let's certify that
the prediction is robust
there were more recent for uh worked by
Rosenfeld and Daisy that um you know
studied Hotel then certified models are
under the instance targeted poisoning
attacks they were more more interested
in obtaining practical methods it's very
very good heuristics some of the results
they had their you know
in real data sets they were pretty good
and our work or the way that I got
interested is really by looking at the
experiments
but what we try to do today is you know
um
so I can understand you know
analyze learnability in these context
under what conditions we can learn
rigorous all right
I should also say that bloom and Company
they also have a work that they looked
at the instance targeted
uh learning but they focus on what is
called the clean label attacks which is
a very very interesting type of attacks
what they mean is that I'm going to give
you data points we could correct labels
not the ones that I showed that you
change the labels the it is that they're
correct if you but what they're doing is
that changing the distribution and then
by changing the distribution suddenly
the classifier is going to change and
you're going to make a mistake well if
you don't change the features
uh no here all the data points are
correctly classified by the original
uh classifier but you know you go very
close to the boundaries and put a lot of
data points in some particular point and
then you tell
um
yes that's the advantage
so in the first part two theorems
the first part I'm going to talk about
when is learning possible and this is a
work with the G and Mohammed and in the
second part I'm going to briefly talk
about
what is the optimal risk that we can
obtain
and this is a work by Steve
all right
so when I say when learning is possible
I have to tell you what do I mean by
learning and here we are going to look
at a very classical setting which is
called the pack learning I have a domain
X these are the set of images I have the
concept class h
learning is a nothing but a distribution
D or known over the the pair right of
the domain and the labels
and we say that the concept class H is
pack learnable
if there exists a learning algorithm
with the following property
for any distribution D and any number
Epsilon Delta between zero and one
when we run the algorithm on n
data points that is
that depends on
Epsilon Delta
with probability one minus Delta the
risk is going to be at most Epsilon what
is the risk it is a zero one risk
the probability of error the learning
algorithm whether it gets
the training
set s
on a new data point x
it incorrectly
uh predicts okay so this probability of
error it should be less sense
this is the pack learning
what you would like to understand is
that
when we have data poisoning under what
condition pack learning is called
so most of the talk about it is going to
be about you know realizable study at
the very end I'm going to talk about the
agnostic setting which is much more
complicated
okay
so here
as you said
so we're going to Define what is the Ada
ball of s is going to be the set of
samples that we obtain by replacing at
most data fraction of the examples in
the training data that's the playground
of the adversary the adversary can
change Ada fraction of the data
the learner goal is boils down to
minimize the adversarial risk
which is
defined as the probability that
if there exists a sample as Prime in
this data ball
such that you replace svds prime it
prompts the wrong answer
because if such a set S Prime exists the
address is going to use it and you're
going to have a wrong answer we want to
minimize this probability that's the
risk
and this is a definition that captures
the adversaries that even know what is a
test Point X and Y and this is what this
is called targeted data poisoning the
addressing knows the target based on the
target it wants to make sure
okay
so let's consider a weak adversary what
what do we mean by weak adversary is an
adversary that knows the rule you're
using but doesn't have access to the
randomness that you're using all right
so you you can use a randomized
algorithm
and the adversary doesn't know
what is the randomness that you use
and it's going to be very critical for
this reason
so what we show yes
realization
it doesn't know what yeah so let's see
what what
so the first result is the following in
this weak adversary
if the fraction of the data points that
the
adversary changes
is sublinear
then pack learning is possible and not
only possible with proper patch learning
is possible meaning that you're going to
return a hypothesis from the class
and the idea is by using sub sample
so how does it work
um let's go to the next one
we know that the original the assumption
is that the original problem was learned
pack learning okay
with these many samples in order to
achieve Epsilon Delta
tax learning guarantee
you're going to up sample
you're going to sample
the minimum number n such that this
fraction
is at least
the square of what was uh
before Pac-Man
so we sampled more data points
and now
you're going to sub-sample
why
the adverse is going to choose
a few samples and change them right
because it obviously doesn't know the
randomness that we're using we can
substance randomly from these points
so
how many samples these many samples
and these many samples is exactly this
number here
and the reasons are twofold first of all
this set of sub-sample
points is large enough that if you look
at this sub-sample data points it's a
learn you can learn it without attack
you learn if there was no attack and
look at this subsample you'll learn
with the same guarantees of Epsilon
built
the second reason is that so it's large
enough
but it is small enough that it's not
going to collide with the choice of the
address
the probability that this set contains
any contaminated data point is going to
be small
right so it is a small with very high
probability Delta over 2 is not going to
contain any data point that adversary
changed
and
it's going to be a pattern okay
good
but this strategy only works if the
adversary doesn't know the randomness
if you have a strong adversary that
knows a randomness
then we need to change a strategy okay
basically there you know the randomness
of the learner should be fixed and the
adversary now changes the training set
knowing the Learners randomness
and
here interestingly we can show that
again as long as
the number of examples that the
adversary changes is sublinear In N
the problem is password but this time
it's going to be improper meaning
the classifier that we are going to
Output is not going to be one of the
classifier from the class from the
hypothesis class
and the reason is that what we are going
to do is to use majority voting so we
are going to train a set of
hypothesis and take the majority vote
and the majority vote of the set of
hypothesis is not in general in class
okay
the idea is simple
like before the original problem was
learnable we up sample
now it's going to be a more complicated
function I'm not going to write it down
okay so it's a more complicated function
of N Sub H and Epsilon Delta these many
numbers we have to up sample so more
data points
and then we're going to partition
it's a deterministic partition
the adversary chooses
a number of
data points to change the labels
and the number of partition is going to
be the square root of n times BN is the
total number of partitions that we are
going to have
so what happens is that first of all
without any attack
if if there was no attack
and we look at
learning only from the samples from each
partition the problem is learnable
with the same parameters okay
that's the first that's the reason that
we do
these many partitions
the second is that we can show that
there are not so many partitions that
are contaminated no matter what the
adversary does not so many of them are
going to be contaminated
like
second erasers like each partition is
like a packet and if you're familiarism
detective yeah
because not so many of them are
contaminated and measurable this need to
be great
pigeonhole majority vote
sorry
okay so does a versus
concentrate
it doesn't matter how it concentrates
you can do anything
because there's these many number of
partitions it cannot contaminate all of
them
that means the number of partitions is
more than the amount of samples the
administration can contaminate uh
[Music]
uh so this is a this is exactly the
number of partitions here and the number
of contaminations in the end
the square root of 10 times
so it's going to be so b b n is the
square root is going to be something
right
not all of them are going to be
contaminated
okay
the converse
is also true
that suddenly if you have a linear
fraction even one percent or zero one
percent or any linear fraction
contaminated by the adversary hack
learning is not possible
right so there is a phase transition
here
and
actually there is a simple example to
show that we let's assume that the data
points are only on these two rings
okay
so
it's uniform so this is a
three-dimensional ball and the data is
going to be concentrated on two rings
with the equal probability
and if I want
uh and the adverse it wants to change
the label of this point
and it's going to place
it's going to replace add a half
of the points in this ring at a half of
the points of this ring originally it
was possible to
uh with the error zero
to classify now a classifier that
has error zero is going to be tilted and
you can you can push the error to one in
this case yes so that's what I
understand like uh in the previous
setting so even if it's like you could
poison n over log log and log log in
then
it doesn't affect the Delta is that just
my question it is possible yeah so
yeah it is possible the number of up
sampling depends on those
kind of similar to
still remember you know information
theory of crypto there was a special
privacy application it's very similar to
that and the people Mama twisty one of
the co-authors is a cryptographers
oh yeah
good so the way that I would like to
think about these following is as
follows that you know learning on the
poisoning is supporting you know in
general we have a set of points some of
them are good if you train on those data
points you get a very good model
some of the data points are bad if you
train on them the model that you get is
not going to be very good
there are some data points that are
originally good
but they're vulnerable they're very
close to the bad ones and these are the
ones that the adversary can
flip and make them bat
why
so learning on the poisoning is possible
if as you collect more and more data
the collection of vulnerable and bad
points becomes smaller and smaller
this is something perfection
we are assuming that the up sampling
from
you can always have sample more than you
add this so you can hurt you right
uh yeah these are once I'm inside the
control room of the grid I can
okay so the assumption is that the in
the pack line right so the pack learning
is you give me how many data points and
then I give you know Epsilon Delta I
give you how many data points
it is under this framework
you might say well you cannot get more
than 10 000 data points that's a
different framework and yeah the results
are these are more essential
yeah or it suggests you should train
with small
to be more robust yeah so partitioning
partitioning and voting is very crucial
you you just need an upper bound though
on the amount of poisoning right yeah
yeah
it is I mean if you want to learn
sorry I might have missed it but when
you audition
is it do you just need one single point
in order to poison the whole partition
or
the
um
the uh yes let's say that yeah
if there is a one single point here but
you don't know which partition is is
poison right so you train on all the
partitions some of them are not good but
the majority vote will take care of
okay
next question
uh so in the first case we need to
sample that square
examples from like the way into measure
it
um that means that actually you need to
learn and more like in order to find the
system you need to do it that way we
need to perform some optimization right
to find it but still it is
to find the best range
uh good so in the when you do their up
sampling yeah
um in the first one that the adversary
didn't know about the randomness you
still need one because you saw sample
that after that and the second one
that's correct each sub model you have
to learn yes that's the point
foreign
now let me briefly talk about the second
part
because this just you know in the first
one we just scratch the surface what you
know you know whether learning is
possible or not we didn't talk about you
know what is the risk what is the
optimum risk
okay
and that is the the second part of the
talk
um
so
just to recall briefly H is a concept
class Ada is a number between zero one
that's a fraction right
the data points that you can poison
and we can Define the optimal Ada
adversarial risk with respect to the
concept class
as the following quantity so
just forget about the int if you have a
learner
that's going to be
the risk of the learner under the
hardest distribution
right without the you have one learner
what is there is under the hardest
distribution and then you you minimize
over
all possible alerts that's the optimum
address service
and then
what we can show
is that the optimal adversary risk
is going to be
Ada
times the VC Dimension and this is cut
is an upper and lower bound that match
so that's a crisp characterization of
the risk
in a realizable case
the idea is very simple it's exactly
like before I just put it in I have to I
have you have a question I have five
minutes of both
yeah it's we're done
uh I I realized that I you know my my
slides are not
very complicated so I put something that
is a little bit more complicated but
then I realized it as you know what what
we had before it's the same idea
partition and vote but it's a more
careful analysis of partition vote this
is the number of partitions this is the
number of data points you need partition
you train and then you take the majority
vote
that is how we get the result
right
now
for the realizable case we understand
almost everything
for the agnostic case it becomes much
more complicated
so in the agnostic case
what we have is that now there is no
realize there is no hypothesis that
achieves error zero what we are doing is
that we compute the with the best
hypothesis in class right and that is
the optimum risk
so in the agnostic case what we can show
is that
the risk so there exists a deterministic
learner whose risk is going to be c
times opt
plus
ETA times the BC Dimension this is what
we had before
this is this is the Ops that we are
competing against
the issue with this bound is that c is
more than one
in diagnostic setting we usually want C
to be one
so that this is opt plus something
then suddenly we get the best result
that we get is c times that it's not
very satisfying
and it turns out that
at least for deterministic setting it is
unavoidable
six should be at least two
and let me finish with Y so everything
that I showed you was about the upper
bound let me show
something about the lower bound which is
a very simple
statistical question that you might
any question are just obviously need
probability of error I wanted between
zero and one and then you're adding BC
Dimensions will be very large at a
fraction but Theta can be a very very
small number it can even go to zero
data is a number between zero one
all right
when you want edit to scale at least one
over BC
uh yeah if so if
so the bowel cannot be better than Ops
is
okay for the just to be clear this is
the best you can get
the unsatisfactory aspect of our bodies
at least seems actually
modern world
and in for the tremendous case it should
be at least
now let me say why and it is a very
funny
question that boys into
finding the conflicts
so let's assume that you have two Pi
processes hey H1 and issue only two that
they differ on the prediction of single
context
and our distribution is only supported
on x
these are the labels
all right one data point
I have a hard two hypothesis that and
they say the point some say it is 0
something 1.
the whole thing is basically determined
by this probability the Y is equal to
zero so let's hold this p
I have just today two
here's the thing the adversary chooses p
amphlets and plus one points
if you knew P right what is the best
strategy that you can okay it flips n
plus one coins
tests you on the
right
if you know P you're going to say well
this is going to be heads the ball to P
right it's probably that's because you
don't know P passage you see the
realizations
and then
you're going to estimate p
once you estimate P you're going to say
well I think this is heads
with this probability it tells you that
right so that's a coin flipping that we
have seen actually in the morning
now what the addressee does is also
change the field
data fraction
this is
and now you want to understand
that you want to predict on the test
what did it show is that
is your prediction this is the optimum
and you can make it
this one happens exactly that two
that we saw
production list
all right so
this only works for deterministic
predictions these are an arguments if
you have a randomized predictor this
argument doesn't work
and we don't know how to fix it
let me skip the proper versus improper
we have some results for the proper
learning
maybe the open questions
we actually don't have a
characterization for proper
we only know it for linear classifiers
and then uh we don't have a
characterization for the randomized
agnostic learning
what should be these factors
oh is it really unavoidable or not for
deterministic cases we know that it is
unavoidable to maybe if you have a
randomized policy you can get around
right
okay thank you very much
[Applause]
it's weird minus two we may also make a
T minus three and have at least one
question from the audience we will pass
yes
okay which one to the coins the points
sorry I think there's a silly question
about what why does that expression at
the bottom not depend on Ada
uh that's a very good uh
because p is chosen by the adversary and
the adverty knows what is Ada how many
data points the adversy can change
based on that the address is going to
choose Heat
right
and that is and the fact is that you can
always bring it to one half
once you know you can this is your power
these many data points you can change
and now you're going to select p based
on this knowledge and then you can make
sure that if the learner uses a
deterministic rule
their regret is going to be one half
but yeah that's a sharp I had to add it
as a sharp observation
should have said that
p is chosen with the knowledge of data
it's great
job any other Sharp observations
questions
yes stop
okay so I'm just trying to think about
can you stop this
certification
soft is also okay
I'm just trying to get a sense of
whether you soften the 30 35
I didn't actually talk about
certification it turns out that the same
condition as I said you know sublinear
linear
also block the certification yeah you
can certify the answer
so if the adversary changes a Sublime
number of data points you can certify
that what you're saying
is not going to change between these
many flips
but now I
have a test and see if there are
they did the right thing and they really
took me a reasonable certification or
should I try like yeah so as well I'm
trying to reverse the problems right
because we are in this irf I think that
we have to pass the model there is a lot
I see so uh you want to use this so as
long as you know that the average rate
cannot change uh more than uh it's a
linear fraction you can search
yes
by partitioning and majority vote
guarantees certification too
yeah
but do you have a value for that oh yeah
we actually I think in the paper we have
some ridiculous value for that because I
was wondering whether you can actually
show that you could get two by possibly
reducing your voting to something like
your neighbors
becomes like an instance at over and
park like you're basically just uh you
know consider some sort of like a super
sample
right that's a very good point
we didn't do that
we were happy with two two I mean I'm
just saying like but you know get two in
the achievability yes right yes
um this content is not true in the
alphabet
it's C right and I'm hiding let's see
it's yeah I'm just saying like you know
but you might be okay now I get what
you're saying because for them in some
other ways you are using basically the
base Bound for yeah yeah that is uh
sure but then yeah maybe maybe voting is
like a sequence of one years neighbor
type things and then you do okay
um so the the strategy where you
partition and then train a bunch of
different models and everybody wrote
like it does seem like that's adding a
whole lot of effort to train a bunch of
separate models even though your deal
like so with even if it's only a few
betas that are poisoned do you think
that's fundamental like there's no way
around having to do that or maybe this
okay
yeah I don't know of any way of doing
that without uh majority
I'll just add the point of there's two
two main ways of doing private machine
learning I want to keep the issue now
that is pate which is
aggregate your segregate you partition
your data and then you open the vote in
any trans model based off those notes
and so you get privacy
after that but you kind of get this for
free yeah
so I I don't know of any other like
unless you have sub models that many of
them are good and then you do that
majority vote all right that's why the
proper learning I think is important
right this is an improper life
if you get to a proper learner which
that would be super cool
thanks to everybody everything